it will haunt you every night whatever
it is no one should have to encounter
that kind of evil except you girls I
think you can handle it oh oh good
thanks
we have a gift we see what no one else
is willing to see we do things others
can't do those buses if there's a
paranormal problem we are the ones to
answer the call hello
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
what do we think of these ghostbusters
are they to be taken seriously okay you
sweaty freaks about to say okay so I
don't know if there was a race thing or
a lady thing but I'm mad as hell there's
a bigger picture at hand here someone is
creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity we're gonna need a
bigger boat
hey guys check it out let me I was born
to be a Ghostbuster
oh man that's so not good
something big is going to happen the
word we're looking for is apocalypse
yeah the government's trying to claim
the event isn't supernatural we don't
want a panic
you don't want miss area especially you
don't move you gotta ya know I'm tired
no no I'm just gonna go ahead and take
off how about that I don't really think
that's a good no going to take off don't
piss off the ghost really oh sorry
I liked you lau Holtzman you're a
brilliant engineer wow ultimen is the
hard scientist she's the hardware nut
she's a genius special she's bizarre
what she's in charge of perfecting the
machinery I got some pretty cool stuff
cooking up over here if you wanted she's
to turn your head um I improved beam
accuracy by adding a plasma shield to
the RF discharge chamber I have
cryocooler to reduce helium boil off and
did of it all we got a freakin Faraday
cage yes this is the closest character
to my actual self that I've ever played
forgot about my new toy
kate is just unbelievable in this role
I'm just so incredible to watch her
every day Holtzman
come on the hat is too much right is it
the wig or the house
Aaron is a professor at Columbia
University no one's better at quantum
physics than you
I always do that she reunites with Abby
after Abby publishes the book without
your permission
ghosts from our past both literally and
figuratively I don't even know how you
got that I thought I burned those copies
it's on Amazon what it's on books on
tape too only I know how to read so she
has to go and tell Abby to take it down
I'm up for tenure right now and if my
colleagues google my name that is the
first thing that comes up along with a
ghost emoji now thank you very much he
ends up going on a call seeing it goes
hello
that's stuff one everywhere by the way
in every crack very hard to wash off
Aaron is the lever who's had her belief
pressed upon
who is that wasn't fired I'll be back in
10 minutes
so I can go through a bit of a crisis
they should put you back therapy free oh
my god I totally punched him in the face
Aaron wants to be successful in the real
world she wants to be respected they're
calling us frauds we don't want a panic
we don't want mass hysteria hello I'm
here about the receptionist job hi Abby
we spoke on the phone did hello there
okay
dryer hit the deck Kevin he's a big dumb
coffee daughter
it's a Ken doll with the inside scoop
down Kevin hi Kim yes the phone con it's
in the fish tank oh no the one on the
desk that's ringing that one oh that one
he has no idea what I even do what's
this place called again when I watch it
move and go I just want more Kevin here
is your copy of you thank you did you
get sugar in it this time
I hike yeah sure sugars in it waist yes
every word is a huge comedic talent
seriously there's no way that you're
this week this funny this fine that's
not fair he's so funny he's such a funny
improviser can I ask why no no god I
just kept getting dirty sorry I took him
out yes and I work fully crying you're
laughing that hard because of the
president signing on so then it became a
character thank you for him
don't let them or never does that Kevin
thinks he's gonna become a Ghostbuster
too we need to form a group and build
something to fight these data ghosts
that's exactly what we already do here
takes ahold of the equipment gets a part
bill design
performance I look you know I'm one of
the gang now
I asked Kevin to throw together couples
logos for us mm oh you do see how this
might make us look bad is it the boobs
you don't like cuz I can make him bigger
ah they meet Patti because patty shows
up at their headquarters saying that she
was chased by a ghost
uh I'm cool dude hey she saw what they
are talking about so she knows his real
I'm joining the club she reads a lot of
New York history guys are really smart
about this science stuff but I know New
York y'all need me I work for the MTA I
know stuff that y'all don't know up
above us was the first place in New York
that Dame electrocuted people I was on
offer the uniforms the car ah ah you
didn't disclose that the vehicle was
gonna be a hearse my uncle owns a
funeral home not an enterprise
rent-a-car Leslie Jones is the most
unapologetically herself human being
I've ever encountered no that's okay
I don't know if it was a race thing or a
lady thing but I'm mad as hell
she makes me ask all right guilty as
charged what she does with every mind so
fun hey you gotta yeah I'm tired okay no
no no this is just gonna go ahead and
take off how about that don't piss off
the ghost really Leslie has this big
personality
I got one one time I got a tub of soup
and I got one split one time there's not
even any in here that's just a Karen my
character has really always been a
believer we have dedicated our whole
lives to studying the paranormal
now there's sightings all over the city
doesn't matter people are making fun of
her which they always have do you mean
like Patrick Swayze like you shouldn't
behind you make into pottery that's it
then we were all dancing at a summer
camp in the Catskills
and then we sat down and he was behind
me and we made a vase
oh you're combining the two I combined
the apples freeze all you know what's a
good one Roadhouse I love her house it's
her and beefy essence that keeps
everyone moving forward we are on the
cusp of a discovery here
she's a spirit of believing and not
caring what people think
come on ghosts I will not let the
12-year reputation of this fine
institution be besmirched by you you
spell science with the Y and what's
upsetting about that is I don't think
you know that that's wrong just so fun
you give a degree firm they do in the
mashed-potato happy is probably my
favorite character because she's so
driven
you like that
you gotta that came from
we send out to my Ghostbusters Katie
Dippold and I sat down and said like
okay what would we be really bummed if
we didn't see there's a lot of things
proton packs and gos traps is line but
the main number one thing we said was
the ecto-1 in sicily beloved to the
title and film that we know and grew up
on but it's a whole different to the
spin on it the remoteness a New York
City its first day we're gonna be using
the ecto-1 I can borrow a car from my
uncle and y'all won't have to lug all
this heavy equipment around cuz we gotta
get a cart uh you didn't disclose that
the vehicle was gonna be a hearse
I'm sorry my uncle owns a funeral home
not an enterprise rent-a-car paddy
borrows from her uncle and then we
transform it into a dream car
I think it's going to satisfy the taste
buds of the people who love the original
and then they'll love this one too
because it's different I fixed it man
this is so inappropriate for this
vehicle the original one was based on an
old ambulance for this one we found this
Cadillac hearse from 84 and just love
the look of it love the cut of the sleek
lines wanted to kind of make it our own
to keep the fun of the original but also
kind of our own version of it we like
the car the ecto-1 should be called the
act of Tim you cannot do Ghostbusters
without the ecto-1
I got every few decades an event comes
along biblical proportions
what do you mean biblical real wrath of
God type stuff fire and brimstone 40
years of darkness earthquakes volcanoes
dogs and cats living together this Labor
Day weekend hey amigos celebrate the
30th anniversary this is big this is
very big of America's favorite comedy
it's looking at me
he slimed me on the big screen I can't
wait to get a look at this thing okay
brought the dog we better split up
yeah we can do more damage that way oh
are you the keymaster is this a trick
question
no it's the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
review and your staff could please wait
out here we'll take care of everything
ghostbusters
30th anniversary fully restored
presented in 4k in theaters for one week
only we Came we saw we kicked it you
don't come peaceful my name is Aaron
Gilbert doctor of particle physics that
stuff one